hi and welcome back I'll take you
through this lesson on statistical
analysis and business applications in
this lesson you'll learn to define
statistics and differentiate between
statistical and non statistical analysis
you'll also learn about the two major
categories of statistical analysis
namely descriptive and inferential
analysis and their differences you'll
also be able to describe the statistical
analysis process at the calculate mean
median mode and percentile you'll also
be able to represent data distribution
using various methods such as histogram
bell curve and kurtosis you'll also
learn about hypothesis testing
chi-square test types of frequencies and
correlation matrix
let's begin this lesson by defining the
term statistics statistics is the study
of the collection analysis
interpretation presentation and
organization of data it's widely used to
understand the complex problems of the
real world and simplify them to make
well-informed decisions several
statistical principles functions and
algorithms can be used to analyze
primary data build a statistical model
and predict the future outcome
there are two major categories of
statistics descriptive analytics and
inferential analytics descriptive
analytics helps organize the data and
focuses on the main characteristics of
the data it provides a concise summary
of the data you can summarize data
numerically or graphically for example
you can collect all the data about the
visitors to your website for a week and
summarize the data inferential analytics
generalizes the larger data set and
applies the probability theory to draw a
conclusion in this approach a random
sample of data is taken from a
population to describe and make
inferences about the population
inferential statistics is valuable when
it is not convenient or possible to
examine each member of an entire
population let's understand both
categories better through an example
suppose you want to study the height of
a person in an entire population you can
do this in two ways were you to record
the height of each person in the
population it would be a tedious process
instead if you categorize height as tall
medium and small and then take only a
sample from the population this is an
inferential analysis in the descriptive
analysis method you would record the
height of every person in the population
and then provide the data for the
maximum height minimum height and
average height of the population
let's understand the population and
sample through the visual population
consists of various samples a sample is
the part or piece drawn from the large
population for statistical analysis it
can be treated as a subset of the
population a sample should be random to
help ensure that it has all the
characteristics of the population and is
also representative of the population
let's understand the terms statistics
and parameters which we'll be using
throughout this lesson statistics are
quantitative values calculated from the
sample parameters are the
characteristics of the population
suppose you have X 0 X 1 X 2 and so on
until X in a sample from a population
and you want to know some vital
information such as average most
occurring characteristic and so on these
are calculated using formulas displayed
on the screen
mean is the average a typical value
present in the distribution and is
calculated by summing the values and
dividing them by the number of values
variance measures the sample variability
standard deviation explains how spread
out the data is from the mean the
greater the standard deviation the
greater the spread in the data its
measured in the same units as the mean
certain terms are used in statistical
analysis to understand the data and gain
insight into it some of these terms are
as follows search search is typically
used to find unusual data unusual data
refers to those data that doesn't meet
the parameters set at the beginning
inspect inspect refers to studying the
shape of the data set and it determining
how spread out it is characterized
characterized determines the central
tendency of the data conclusion based on
the understanding of search inspect and
characterize we can draw some
preliminary or high-level conclusions
about the data
data distribution is the collection of
data values that are arranged in order
along with the relative frequency or
occurrences to understand any kind of
problem it's important to describe the
data in terms of its spread and shape
using graphical techniques range of the
data indicates the quantitative values
minimum and maximum frequency of the
data indicates the number of occurrences
of any particular data value in the
given data set central tendency
indicates whether the data values
accumulate in the middle of distribution
or toward the end
following are the measures of central
tendency mean the sum of all the values
in the dataset
divided by the number of values median
the data value right in the middle of
the data set or the 50th percentile mode
the data value which is the most common
or frequent let's understand percentile
in data distribution a percentile or a
cent I'll as a measure used in
statistics indicating the value below
which a given percentage of observation
in a group of observations false
for example the 20th percentile is the
value or score below which 20% of the
observations may be found
usually we report percentiles as below
the 25th percentile is called the first
quartile the 50th percentile is called
the median or second quartile the 75th
percentile is called
the third quartile
histogram is a graphical representation
of data distribution first introduced by
Karl Pearson to construct a histogram
the first step is to bin the range of
values that is divide the entire range
of values into a series of intervals and
then count how many values fall into
each interval the bend are usually
specified as consecutive non-overlapping
intervals of a variable the bins must be
adjacent and are usually of equal size
in the graphical representation each bar
represents a group of values also called
bin the height of the bar represents the
frequency of the values in the bin
histograms help assess the probability
distribution of a given variable by
depicting the frequencies of the
observations occurring in a certain
range of values
a normal distribution is the most
commonly used distribution in statistics
it is characterized by its bell shape
and its two parameters mean and standard
deviation a bell curve or normal
distribution it's symmetric around the
mean if you draw a line at the center
you'll get the symmetric shapes on both
sides the mean median and mode of a
normal distribution are equal normal
distributions are denser in the center
and less dense in the tails or sides
normal distributions are defined by two
parameters the mean and the standard
deviation the bell curve is also known
as the Gaussian curve let's understand
the bell curve better
the bell curve is divided into three
parts to understand the data
distribution better P it's where most of
the observations occur and generally the
peak is within one standard deviation
from the mean flanks
they are the areas beyond the peak but
between one and two standard deviations
from the mean
tails they refer to the area far from
the center of the distribution and
considered to be beyond two standard
deviations from the mean usually 5% or
less data falls under this
skewed data distribution indicates that
the tendency of data distribution is to
be more spread out on one side than the
other
in this graphical representation the
data is left skewed mean is less than
median the distribution is negatively
skewed or represents negative statistics
left tail contains large distributions
in this graphical representation the
data is right skewed or positively
skewed distribution mean is greater than
median right tail contains large
distributions let's now learn about
kurtosis another popular measure of data
distribution in a similar way to the
concept of skewness kurtosis is a
descriptor of the shape of a probability
distribution and just as there are four
skewness there are different ways of
quantifying it for a theoretical
distribution and corresponding ways of
estimating it from a sample of a
population depending on the particular
measure of kurtosis that is used there
are various interpretations of kurtosis
kurtosis measures the tendency of the
data towards the center or towards the
tail
platykurtic is negative statistics or
negative kurtosis mesokurtic represents
a normal distribution curve
leptokurtic is positive statistics or
positive kurtosis
hypothesis testing is an inferential
statistical technique to determine
whether a certain condition is true for
the entire population for example in a
manufacturing company the hypothesis is
that every dress manufactured has no
defect a study of each dress
manufactured and noting that effects as
they occur will prove or disprove the
hypothesis that every dress is flawless
a hypothesis test studies two opposing
hypotheses about a population the null
hypothesis and the alternative
hypothesis the null hypothesis is the
statement that has to be tested
usually the null hypothesis is a
statement of no effect or no difference
the alternative hypothesis is the
statement that has to be concluded as
true to quickly summarize alternative
hypothesis it's a research hypothesis
it needs a significant level of evidence
to support the initial hypothesis or
assumption if the alternative hypothesis
Garner's strong evidence reject the null
hypothesis null hypothesis it's the
logical opposite of the alternative
hypothesis it indicates that the
alternative hypothesis is incorrect weak
evidence of alternative hypotheses
indicates that the null hypothesis
cannot be rejected the table explains
how a decision can be made and based
upon the hypothesis testing type one
error
rejects the null hypothesis when it is
true the probability of making type 1
error is represented by alpha type 2
error fails to reject the null
hypothesis when it is false the
probability of making type 2 error is
represented by beta probability value
the probability of observing extreme
values or more extreme than the one
observed calculated from collected data
let's understand the process of
hypothesis testing the first step is to
set the hypothesis
the hypothesis could be null or
alternative the null hypothesis or h0
states that a population parameter is
equal to a value the alternative
hypothesis or h1 states that the
population parameter is different than
the value of the population parameter in
the null hypothesis the alternative
hypothesis is what is believed to be
true or is to be proven true the next
step is to set alpha or choose the
significant level for the population the
third step is to collect the sample from
the population which represents the
characteristics of the population the
final step is to compare the p-value and
alpha you reject the null hypothesis if
p-value is less than alpha and failed to
reject the null hypothesis if p-value is
greater than or equal to alpha this
example shows how clinical trials can be
analyzed suppose a pharmaceutical
company wants to compare a medicine at
manufactures with that of a competitor's
medicine then hypothesis testing can be
the method it adopts
the null hypothesis would be that both
the medicines are equally effective the
alternative hypothesis would be that the
two medicines are not equally effective
there are three types of data on which
you can perform hypothesis testing
continuous data evaluate the mean median
standard deviation or variance if you
take the same example to test the
efficacy of medicine take the
temperature of every person in the
sample after three hours of
administering the medicine this would be
referred to as continuous data binomial
data evaluate the percentage general
classification of data when data is
divided into two categories you obtain a
binomial data supposing the same
population were asked if their fever had
subsided and the answers could be yes or
no then the percentage who said yes
should match the null hypothesis Poisson
data evaluate rate of occurrence of
frequency if the sample is asked about
how many times in a month they use the
medicine and the rate of frequency is
recorded and is then compared to the
null hypothesis where the rate should be
less than a certain number let's
understand the different types of
variables to analyze categorical data
nominal variables have values with no
logical ordering they are independent of
each other and the sequence does not
matter for example in a restaurant you
can order burgers soda and coffee in any
order ordinal variables have values in
logical order however the relative
distance between the two data values is
not clear for example large medium and
small coffee sizes Association indicates
that two variables are associated or
independent of each other for example in
the first data set weather does not
affect the train schedule but in the
second data set it does variables have
dependencies and one changes if the
other changes
chi-square test is a hypothesis test
that compares the observation
distribution of your data to an expected
distribution of data the test is applied
usually when there are two categorical
variables from a single population it's
used to determine whether there is a
significant association between the two
variables chi-square test is used to
test the independence or association
between categorical variables determine
whether a statistical model fits the
data adequately
let's understand the chi-square test
through an example we have a data set of
male purchasers and female purchasers
let's assess whether probability of
females purchasing items of $500 or more
or 0.45 is significantly different from
the probability of males purchasing
items of $500 or more or 0.25 null
hypothesis there is no association
between gender and purchase the
probability of purchase does not change
for $500 or more whether female or male
alternative hypothesis there is
association between gender and purchase
the probability of purchase over $500 is
different for female and male
let's look at the types of frequencies
expected frequencies or Fe the cell
frequencies that are expected in a
bivariate table if the two tables are
statistically independent observed
frequencies or fo there is association
between gender and purchase the
probability of purchase behavior over
$500 is different for female and male if
there is no association between gender
and purchase then the observed frequency
would be equal to the expected frequency
if there was an association between
gender and purchase behavior then the
observed frequency will not be equal to
the expected frequency
the formula for calculating them using
chi-square method is shown here
chi-square is calculated using the
formula shown on the screen
chi-square is the sum of the squared
difference between the observed
frequency and the expected frequency
data or the deviation divided by the
expected frequency data in all possible
categories expected and observed
frequencies require no assumption of the
underlying population both the
frequencies demand at random sampling
let's understand the correlation matrix
a simple matrix can be visualized as an
Excel document with three rows and three
columns a correlation matrix is always a
square matrix that is it has the same
number of rows and columns but it's a
larger set a correlation matrix is
expressed in the form of nxn matrix when
we compare in variables the covariance
is calculated by getting the sample
variance between the variables in
question a correlation coefficient
measures the extent to which two
variables tend to change together the
coefficient describes both the strength
and the direction of the relationship
pearson product-moment correlation the
pearson correlation
evaluates the linear relationship
between two continuous variables a
relationship is linear when a change in
one variable is associated with a
proportional change in the other
variable Spearman rank order correlation
also called Spearman's Rho the Spearman
correlation evaluates the monotonic
relationship between two continuous or
ordinal variables in a monotonic
relationship the variables tend to
change together though not necessarily
at a constant rate the Spearman
correlation coefficient is based on the
ranked values for each variable rather
than the raw data
here is the example of a correlation
matrix calculated for the stock market
we can choose the data variables and
calculate the correlation matrix to
demonstrate this short medium and long
term relationships between them now you
can see why a correlation matrix would
prove useful for traders
we already know that inferential
statistics uses a random sample from the
data to make inferences about the
population this is a valuable method
when each and every member of the
population cannot be studied inferential
statistics can be used only under the
following conditions you have a complete
list of the members of the population
you draw a random sample from this
population using a pre-established
formula you determine that your sample
size is large enough inferential
statistics can be used even if your data
does not meet these criteria inferential
statistics can help determine the
strength of the relationship with your
sample if it's very difficult to obtain
a population list and/or draw a random
sample then you do the best you can with
what you have
inferential statistics is an effective
forecasting tool widely used in
businesses for example companies use it
to predict their finances for future
quarters using current data future
patterns can be inferred
let's now quickly recap what we've
learned in the lesson statistics is the
study of the collection analysis
interpretation presentation and
organization of data statistical
analysis is more reliable as it is based
on numbers and scientific analysis when
compared to non statistical analysis
descriptive and inferential are the two
major categories of Statistics
descriptive takes into account all the
members of the population while
inferential uses only a sample mean
median and mode are measures of central
tendency
while variance and a standard deviation
measure the spread of data the spread of
distribution is called a dispersion and
is graphically represented by a
histogram and a bell curve the shape of
the dispersion is represented as left
skewed right skewed and kurtosis
hypothesis testing is an inferential
statistical technique that is useful for
forecasting future patterns chi-square
test is a hypothesis test that compares
observed distribution to an expected
distribution the correlation coefficient
or covariance measured with the help of
correlation matrix measures the extent
to which two variables tend to change
together
this concludes the lesson statistical
analysis and the business applications
you